in other news the National Rifle
Association begins its annual convention
today testing the organization's support
at a time when deadly mass shootings
remain in the headlines delegates are
scheduled to hear from top political
figures including former president
Donald Trump and his former vice
president Robert Costa is at the
convention site in Indianapolis and
joins us now Bob good morning
good morning this capital city in a red
state is now a Crossroads for the
National Gun debate as well as for the
2024 Republican presidential race and
this event comes just days after a
gunman killed five people in downtown
Louisville in less than three weeks
after a shooter killed three children
and three adults at a Nashville school
here many NRA attendees have told us
they believe those events are tragic but
say the problem isn't too many guns and
argue the legislative focus should be on
mental health and unarming teachers of
you sure to be echoed on stage today and
this weekend Headliners include former
president Trump and former vice
president Mike Pence both champions of
gun rights but this convention comes As
Trump faces mounting legal challenges
including the likely testimony from
Pence about Trump's efforts to overturn
the 2020 election and meanwhile in
Nashville the Republican National
Committee will be meeting there this
weekend for a fundraising event all as
the debate continues in Tennessee over
the recent expulsion of two black
Democratic lawmakers who had been
calling for more gun control legislation
Tony
Bob I know you got a lot of politics to
cover there but you should check out the
exhibits as well I've covered the NRA 14
acres of guns and gear as it says on the
side behind you it is a view of America
thank you very much